so we've got confirmation that there is
going to be a sequel to the batman matt
reeves is coming back to write and
direct robert pattinson is coming back
as batman now of course the question
becomes who's the next villain i could
do a longer video on this i don't have
that many thoughts so first of all don't
have to be the joker i know you teased
him last time save him wait for the
third one or however long down the road
however many you're planning to do save
him do him later for now i want to
suggest someone who i haven't seen
suggested as being the one to go with
and i have specific reason mr zazz the
serial killer who tallies his victims on
his body here's why i want it to be him
there's a very specific aspect of him
that has basically never been done in
any of the adaptations that or times
he's been used because he showed up in
batman begins he showed up and got them
neither of them did this it would be
perfect for a detective focused batman
which is as a serial killer he changes
his mo every single time changes method
the way he hunts down his victims who
the victims are he changes it all the
time which makes him much harder to find
that's good for a detective